Hi guys!
Hi everybody!
Oh hi dance!
Or con dance!
Con dance!
So let's head over to the chatting area.
Real quick, we're waiting for Minto to get back from an idol
meeting.
So it's a little bit of a little little focky time to start
you off.
Yeah, it's your focky warm up.
Focky warm up.
Um, yum, yum, yum.
Are these edible flowers?
I mean, are all flowers?
Wait, are all flowers edible flowers?
That's a great question.
Except for the poison.
Well, actually, anything is edible.
At least what?
Um.
I mean, that's one way of putting it.
Guys, don't eat random flowers.
Don't eat random flowers.
Make sure that they are the kinds that you're supposed to be
eating.
Yeah.
Well, or the kinds that are edible, at edible and not
poisonous but technically everything is edible once yeah
vicky i heard there were earthquakes where you're at please
stay safe yeah it was really weird it was very you feel it
yes it was very it's quite far from where i am i hope
everyone in the affected area is okay but yeah it was really
like low how do i explain it like like a lot of slow shaking
It's the kind of earthquake where I don't know if it's
shaking or if I'm just like shaking myself, you know, it was
that kind of thing.
Yeah, no, it felt really odd, actually.
Hope everyone in the affected area is okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hope everyone's all right.
I'm glad you're all right.
Oh, thank you.
I think it was, I'm so sorry if I get this wrong.
I think it was Iwate or something, but I think it was quite
big.
Yeah, so I hope everyone in the affected area.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hope everyone in the affected area is okay.
Yeah, yeah, my paintings on my wall were like shaken.
That's how I knew that it wasn't me.
I was like, oh, no, no, it's definitely an earthquake.
Yeah, yeah, anyways.
Have you ever seen, you know when you have like flower
decorations on cakes, yeah?
And they like make, like the flowers in your hair, but they
make them out of like icing.
They always look so nice, don't they?
Yeah, they look so nice.
Oh, I just want to, well, I just like taking the frosting
off of cakes anyway.
Just, well, well, well.
Oh, well.
Are you were... You know...
What's the word?
No, what's the word?
Raw dogging frost.
I don't know if I've ever heard...
I don't know if I've ever heard raw dogging frost.
No, that's not it.
Is that the word?
I mean...
No, no, no.
The thing is like...
So, one time my singing teacher said I was cute.
Because she offered me a K.
And I broke the cake up into like six pieces and then took
the cream and I spread it evenly on each of the six pieces.
I like to, I think very hard about how I eat my food.
I have a specific order in which I eat it so that like the,
the, I force myself to eat the most nutritious stuff first.
Or like the stuff I don't want to eat first so that it gets
eaten.
Are you saying that the most nutritious stuff is always the
stuff you don't want to eat, Phoebe?
Oh no, not always.
But sometimes.
I mean, chat.
We can understand.
Yeah, yeah.
You mean you can raw dog frosting?
Well, you're eating a dog raw.
Huh?
What?
No.
That is not that.
That is definitely not what we were saying.
Okay, hang on.
Let me just tweet that we're live as well.
Did you tweet that we're live?
I did not tweet that we're live before we were live.
Oh, I'm not kidding.
Whoops.
Oops.
Oh, I must warn everybody, too, that I might pop, I may,
like, fairy dust in and out of existence during this stream
sometimes, because, uh, my, the heat has been destroying my
internet, and my chat knows the heat's been destroying my
internet, so, I might phase in and out of, oh, never, never
permanently, sometimes I just, I just, achoo, and then I
accidentally pop into the next dimension.
but then I'll come back to you always.
I'll always return to you.
Aw, you know what?
I think MVP was meant to be in the same dimension.
The same...
Vicky, your volume.
My volume?
Apparently you are a little bit quiet.
I am quiet.
Or you're quite quiet.
Quite quiet.
Oh, I think it's just you are...
Okay, sorry, guys.
That is not the case.
It is just Phoebe is loud.
I'm sorry.
I have turned Phoebe down.
I'm loud.
No, no, you're not, you're not.
No, no, don't worry, don't worry.
Don't worry, Phoebe.
You're perfect, perfect, perfect as you are.
Yeah, or Phoebe, very loud.
Yeah, I think it was that way round, guys.
I can't make my microphone any louder.
I should have, I should have eaten the mic, just be like,
Hello, thank you.
I've got, I've always wanted to do that to see what it
sounds like, but I don't really want to, like, you know,
like, what if it damages the microphone?
How is the microphone?
All that saliva.
I don't want to try.
I love my mic too much to try that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Maybe with like someone else's mic.
Maybe I'll eat someone else's microphone.
Just like on an off call.
I'm just like, hey, can I do something real quick?
Well, I've always wondered about ASMR this, you know, like,
do they really put the like, do they really eat them?
microphone what ASMR is you listening I'm not listening to
it but I just kind of assume well some people have it I saw
I saw in the title it was like stomach ASMR and I was like
what did they put the mic in their stomach or did they eat
it how did they do that what is this more like rather than
the relaxing ASMR is this more like morbidly curious ASMR
like what does it sound like inside someone's stomach time
to find out an asmr mic but i don't know if i'm supposed to
what am i supposed to do i have one but i have not i've been
like too scared to try i was like maybe i'll ask like nimi
to teach me some time or i don't know but like i feel like
you've got a very relaxing soft voice so i think it would
work really well i i have tried asmr previously and British
version of that.
Well, some people want loud British ASMR.
I don't think it was.
Oh, you know what?
You could do like tea party ASMR.
Tea party.
The clinking, the clinking of the tea cups, you know?
That would be nice.
Wait, I would love...
Wait, I've...
I did try...
So, once upon a time, I tried doing tea party ASMR, but it
was playing sound bites.
It wasn't actually like...
It was like playing sound bites and then whispering into a
regular microphone.
And it was like four years ago, I was like, I don't have an
ASMR mic, but if I play these stereo sound bites and I
whisper to a regular microphone, maybe...
Yeah, maybe it'll work.
You gotta start somewhere, you know?
Yeah.
It can be if you want it to be exactly chat.
You gotta just be positive about it.
I would love to hear you ASMR, though.
I better be really nice.
an asmr imagine like 4d and you can like smell the flowers
at the same time oh when will streams be 4d so we can like
do it like a cooking stream or a baking stream and you can
smell it wait i feel like people could use this for evil
though yeah i was gonna say hopefully 4d streams in time for
cleaning the keyboard hey guys no to be fair it doesn't
smell it's smell
I hope it doesn't smell.
Nikki, what is it?
Are you saying that you're...
Are you saying your keyboard probably smells, but you're
desensitized to it?
I don't think so.
I think it's just dusty.
4D Durian stream, yes?
No, I don't think that will be happening.
No.
Oh, no.
No, no.
No.
absolutely not um we could actually we could start off we we
we have some leftover marshmallows for us individually if
you want to start off with those give it a little go shall
we do a little bit of that yeah while we're waiting for it
meant to get back from the idle meat yeah all right give me
a second i do i do have them somewhere okay give me give me
two seconds let me find one
I love this Bossa Nova version.
It's so nice.
Scratch and Sniff Phoebe's dream.
I do...
Huh?
I don't...
I...
Did you like Scratch and Sniff books when you were a kid?
Did you have Pat the Bunny?
What was Pat the Bunny?
The heck is Pat the Bunny?
Pat the Bunny!
Hold on.
By Dorothy Kun-ha.
You did!
You did?
We know those ones where you like the the fluffy animals the
fluffy animals and you like pet it Yes, and sometimes
there's scratch and sniff as well.
Yeah, it's so cute All right, so cute Phoebe it's time for
your first question.
Are you ready?
This is a Phoebe question from the from the Denshi.
Oh Which do you I can't read some of these which do you
think is funnier?
I'm gonna be honest I Wait, okay 67 6 7 Auf Zane, I think it
is Wait, no, it's more like Zane Not Zane from one direction
Zane It's Lochi Lochi I think Oh That's cute Sounds cute I
don't know if I'm doing it right I've been practicing my
Mandarin But I don't know if that's it Ceciete I know that
one Ceciete And what is that?
What is it in Hangul I can't I cannot read that Ceciete has
a nice ring to it Doesn't it?
Ceciete It's kind of fun to say Yeah I think so Whoa Do you
notice there's like Oh, well, not for all the language.
For the romance languages, there's still the alliteration.
That's cool.
Six seven!
Oh, Mint is back from Idol meeting.
Give me a second.
Welcome back.
Let me just load her in.
Thank you.
Boop.
you guys stop talking i think they can still hear you hello
hello oh they can see you oh it just said oh it said that
discord said that my call disconnected oh oh wait i think i
think i thought that was me what yeah i'm pretty sure i'm
pretty sure they can hear us i think anyway we're back um i
was just asking feby a fun question um that you might want
to see i know Yeah.
Minto always watching over us.
Always watching.
Haunting.
Which is funnier.
I wish I could read the two that I cannot read.
I don't know.
Sex even.
It sounds like more like like like a rabbit.
Like, you know, like some kid coming up to you being like,
sexy, and it makes me...
Wait, yesterday, I went on a walk, and this child came up to
me.
Well, I heard from across the park.
They were like, they were like, six, seven, six, seven.
And then kid, kid on his scooter rides by me, looks at me
with a glint in his eye, and goes, six, seven.
And then I look at him and I do the gesture, and he's like,
woo, we probably get each other.
connecting with the same language word you know the world
was smaller the world was more was more peaceful in that
moment oh it's so nice being able to connect with that kid
oh toddler to toddler communication shut up shut up what did
he think you were a child vv let's go to the next Let's move
on to this question.
Actually, we don't even have to.
Do we want to do any more marshmallows?
Or do we want to go on to the main event of today?
Main event.
Main event, please.
Guys, thank you so much for...
A hundred K views and more.
And more!
Ippie, Ippie, Ippie, Ippie.
Ippie, Ippie.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
No, seriously, we appreciate it so much.
And we want to celebrate with you guys.
And we've got a lot of fun, little, fun secret things to
share with you.
Little behind the scenes.
Yeah.
Behind the scenes to share with you as a celebration.
But first, we actually, have we...
Yeah, we have reacted to the MV like once together, right?
Once?
Like, did we?
I don't think together.
Oh, no, did we?
individually yeah we did individually oh we kind of did
because we were in chat together but not on stream together
so yeah yeah yeah yeah i think we like raided into it right
so we'll be able to we'll be able to we'll be able to do
that actually watch it together for the first time to start
off with yeah um do you want how do you want to do this do
you want me to pause at all or do we just want to vibe or do
you want to shout be like pause vicky pause it How are you
feeling?
We get, you know, we'll shout.
I feel like we'll shout if we want to pause.
What is it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, alright, then that's what we'll do.
Give me a second, guys.
Let's just move over to the other room and turn off this BGM
as well.
Alright, yosh, yosh, yosh, yosh, yosh.
Here we go, guys.
Oh, oh, here we go.
You ready?
I don't know how loud it's going to be.
I have one question for you.
real quick vicky can you uh turn up the quality of the of
the stream to us just a little bit just a uh i don't think i
can because i don't have nitro unless anyone oh nitro no
wait can i what if i just gift you nitro right now tell what
about setzuna to gift you nitro right now setzuna do you
want this like funny i think i already asked stya to give me
nitro at some point when i give me nitro like real quick but
it was only one month three friends a two-week nitro trial
and become the mvp of the group chat here i'm sharing a
trial to you oh what's your nitro girl up i'll send the next
one we'll just keep sending yeah thanks thank you we'll have
we yeah we'll have like oh wait two we'll have like six
whole weeks no no 12 whole weeks of i mean i could just get
nitro i keep forgetting to get it but wait so did someone
give me should i be able to do it now okay let me try um
yeah yeah yeah the stream quality all right go to your dms i
think i think you can start trial okay q q q q q um i think
yippee Oh,
are you okay?
Yes, thank goodness.
Okay, I don't really want to do this now.
Is it urgent?
Oh, no.
I mean, I just...
I might not be able to see some details of the video, but
it's okay.
I'm so sorry.
I do okay.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Maybe not now.
If it's like, if you think it's okay level, maybe not now.
My brain cannot handle.
Is that okay?
Let's just give it a try.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Here we go, guys.
Are you ready?
Or I think if you take it out of studio mode, it'll be okay.
Yeah, I think if it's out of studio mode, it'll be okay.
If you take it out of studio mode.
Oh.
Keep going down.
There you go.
Is that safe?
Yeah, yeah, it's safe.
I've never done it.
Hawaii.
You've already switched out of me.
So you're okay.
Okay, is it fine?
Yeah, there it is, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm going.
Are we ready?
Yes.
You jump!
Yay!
You're going.
We are...
Dance at the top, EXT!
The world that we wanted to know...
The drone shots are so cool.
Yes.
Remember how many times it took for us to attack this wet
jump?
No.
Too many and we still messed it up.
In a way, I thought it turned out real nice.
It's good, it's nice, but...
We weren't really good of this kid.
Vegeta is my favorable time.
Are you alright?
I love stickers so much.
I was not realizing they were gonna make the stickers from
many different angles.
That guy.
This scene, you know, the little jig?
Can we, like, go back a little bit and, like, look at it
again?
Because you did, you notice his little jig that he does at
the beginning?
It's so stunning.
And look what he's doing.
What is he doing?
The hands, the like, oh, yeah.
He's loitering.
That's what loiterers do.
You know when the knees and Tomodachi live do a little
dance?
and stuff it's like we should have gotten a fake cigarette
or something like so he's just gonna
and here why he's running like that i mean why are you like
that or you look like that i feel like i'm also running
really similarly i know it's so good i mean everyone's ready
with their own i love your people people hammer too mental
yeah i think you get to hit anything You had to leave it!
Oh no, you had to leave it!
Let's go honour the pico-pico hammer again.
Oh my pico-pico hammer!
No!
Does that mean that somebody, Adenchi in Japan could search
for it and find it somewhere?
I don't know, maybe one of the cleaning ladies took it home
for their kids, I hope so.
Aw, hopefully.
Wait, you literally just put it in a bin.
Wait!
I left it in my hotel room.
Oh, in the hotel room.
I just imagine like a pico-pico hammer just like sticking
out of a bin just like what is that?
I love we really hit that pose yeah we did right it looks so
good I don't think we discussed beforehand exactly how it
was going to go either but it was close to yeah I kind of
love the Steiner I know the Steiner a running transition
yeah so good and the different pen lines each with our
little individuality very sweet thanks donkey hotel i want
all of these are just like gif nice someone please make a
million gifts of this video i can't wait to show the part
right around here this part where it just fighting the beans
yeah the uncut version without us there oh yes so i feel
like i don't know if you guys noticed i feel like there are
different levels of uh kicking who would you say we're there
we're there who would you guys say is doing the most the
most the most kick
good now they kick real good it's a vicky punch not a vicky
kick i mean that's true he means like actually kicking him
was i i don't remember i thought my kicks were a bit
pathetic i should have should have done more he's just so
good i love i love mincell pose here oh damn cute yeah guys
i'm not gonna i'm quite proud of how high that leg went you
were chatteling your inner cheer you were good baby look at
this there I was like, can I channel my childhood karate?
Can I?
This was fun.
God, man, you constructed these puppets so well.
They're so, so cute.
Yeah, these puppets are the cutest thing ever.
Big ops, Minto.
And they're also surprisingly detailed.
Like, there are a lot of detail in them.
Yeah, it's so cute.
to yeah to at least hit the main points i feel like for each
person the big points is yeah i love them these animated
bits every single frame has such personality so good oh wait
i don't think i've seen this frame before i accidentally can
i just say mental fleshbang gives me life oh i'm trying to
pause it on the bit i like this bit i love this yeah oh god
it's so good it's so sick We look so cool.
We're so badass.
Yeah!
The mic drop.
I didn't know if people could tell it was a mic drop or not.
I want to watch it again.
Whoa.
With your sweet smiling face, it's too good.
But I know that.
I am happy that they so they provided us with so many
different angles for the the heads which was amazing i
wasn't expecting that but but just one expression happy
because we're so happy to explode things i mean it would
have been kind of funny to have a slight like you know the
eyebrows slightly you know like slightly evil eyebrows here
yeah mischievous yeah
right can i set the record straight this is not a fart oh
wait phoebe I'm coming back.
Phoebe!
Oh, oh, it's back?
It's back!
Phoebe, did you run?
Did you run from my fart?
Is that what happened?
Oh, I think, I, you know, I love you so much, Vicky.
There's only a, I love you no matter what your farts are
like.
Oh, thank you so much, Phoebe.
I was not writing.
That's so sweet.
Thank you so much.
Anyway, it's not a fart.
Thank you.
That was my TED Talk.
It's not, it's not.
I don't see why, oh, Phoebe.
Phoebe, Phoebe.
I promise I was not running.
I promise.
It's not happening yet.
Exactly the same time, both.
I swear to God, I'm not trying to.
Phoebe.
Anyway, let's move on.
Let's move on.
You know, though, these explosions didn't really smell at
all.
I don't know.
No, they didn't.
They really did.
No, but they were warm.
They were warm.
I was going to say they weren't even that warm, but I guess
you guys would have felt it more probably with what you were
wearing.
But like for me, I didn't really feel them.
Oh, good.
I feel like I was expecting them to be way hotter than they
were.
So I had like a performance the week after and there were
little bits that were slightly, slightly melted off just a
little bit.
No, wait, wait, wait, what's wrong with it?
The rhinestones in the black were like melting off the wall.
Wait, oh my gosh.
So I was like, I was like, I prefaced it when I sent this to
Stephanie who did my outfit.
I was like, you'll be very happy to see your outfits in this
video.
You'll be, you're gonna scold me a bit to know that it was
slightly melted off in the back.
Oh no.
Just a little.
I mean, I guess worth, hopefully.
Worth?
No, totally worth.
Yeah.
We were in the sun all day that day too, so it was like
probably the sun's heat and then the heat from the fire.
You're like a little s'more.
It's a little s'more, yeah.
MVP s'mores.
Oh, so sweet.
Gram cracker and marshmallow and chocolate.
Well, I hope you can see like the Melty next time and be
like, yeah, that was from a fun day we exploded things it's
a happy it's like it's like when you get like a little like
scar from something fun that happened you know when you look
back and you're like yeah that was a good time oh so sweet i
love this yeah oh my gosh like the timing hits perfect well
good we were really great at directing us with these you
were you know okay i love that photo you posted up with the
explosion in the background and the moe moe king that was
like yeah we had the professional cameraman there too he was
so awesome yeah there was a we had an eccentric cameraman
yes love that guy we loved him i'm so sorry can you remember
any of his quotes i i think there's fun to share if you can
remember I can remember one specific one that I'm not gonna
repeat I have a feeling I know exactly what the time I don't
remember yeah I don't think you were there at that point
don't worry I will just not worry yeah you were still
getting changed yeah yeah yes but no he was he was a very
very fun very nice guy very fun yes he was like an America
boo you guys so he was very like yeah he had a cowboy hat on
yeah he's like oh los angeles i know los angeles yeah
actually i think i remember when steiner like messaged the
quarry and he was just like yeah we're a we're a band or
something or like whatever until the guy was just like oh
yeah there's like some metal band coming to america amazing
video i don't know how i don't remember how we got this
impression of i think specifically he thought because
because steiner's british right i think they thought it was
like british punk rock british british was heading up and
they were like wow that's so cool wow and then we show up
three idols so funny yeah yeah and he was like he was just
like i really love like punk metal bands and he was like he
was like what was it what else he like runs a horror themed
bar somewhere yeah yeah that sounded so cool he was like
giving us stuff he was like dude like anime here's a bag
with anime on it yeah he's pulled random goodies out and he
was like santa but america boo santa america boo santa yeah
with a cowboy hat love him oh my gosh i want to see the
alternate reality of steiner's uh british punk rock band
doing this though to be honest yeah he could spearhead it
with his yeah his outfit don't worry just pretend just when
i disappear pretend i'm just tripping and falling on the
ground and picking myself up i like it says left phoebe
every time i don't think i think i can do about that i'm
sorry i think it's gonna keep coming up i'll show you a way
late next hour later sorry oh there is a way i'm sorry yeah
no no it's okay it's okay unfortunately we're gonna keep
seeing it for now um is she back phoebe i'm back oh it
didn't bring oh there you go ha ha you're back all right
let's continue
Did you hear that this was a bed sheet, guys?
I heard that.
I did hear that.
Yes.
Because he lost his outfit or something.
I don't know what happened.
Yeah, this was a...
I remember seeing this.
I was like, I don't remember us filming this.
We need to film this.
So where was this?
Where was this filmed?
It's like his bedroom, I think.
Really?
I mean, look, no, it's in the sand.
The desert, look.
Yeah, yeah, the desert, guys.
Oh, the back ones are probably made by the...
Yeah, okay, I see.
They're made by the little polygons.
We did a fantastic job.
I want to just highlight this part because Minto looks so
cute.
So cute.
Oh, we're going to do it.
to help down we're gonna help down oh i love the fishing
wings they're so good oh thank you so much oh oh she's like
puss and boots and shrek that's how i feel oh my god it is i
can hear the music and i'm just like oh so cute oh yeah so
so sweet maybe i should just have this picture for when
Phoebe disappears.
Just in the middle of us.
So cute.
He understood the assignment so well for this.
They really, really did.
Unvisible.
I mean, this is how I feel with you guys is that, like, I
can always rely on you.
Aww.
That's very sweet.
Well, if anyone Steiner bully, we attack.
Honestly, if anyone tries to try to stay elephant, hurt our
Phoebe, this is us.
This is me and Minto straight away.
Yeah.
No, get out of here.
Get out, Steiner.
I do really like this bit with the fiery eyes.
I know.
Why?
You guys look so cool.
Yeah.
I love the broken camera effect.
It's so cool.
Right.
We look like movie stars in this bit.
Look at this.
This is crazy.
Isn't there another shot of this, but we're running towards
the camera?
Yeah, I think so.
I mean, they used that one in the end, but there was one.
There was an...
We were running for our lives is what we were doing.
No, literally.
They were like, it's going to explode.
You've got to run.
And it's like, okay.
They were like, run slower at first.
And then as soon as you hear the explosion, speed up for
your own sake is what they said.
And I was like, what?
There is like an explosion.
shot of this i guess we didn't use it yeah it still looks so
cool though the drone how many running takes were there each
of these explosions we didn't one take because i mean you
can't really we did practice but yeah yeah but it was pretty
much pretty much one take with the guy jumping pretending to
be an explosion amazing yeah yes the best little frog oh
this is so pretty paused on such a pretty part oh it's
pretty i like the pixels and the flower it's very oh i feel
like this bit's like a very i don't know key bit for a lot
of people like um like my my friend has a a small child and
she was like wiki i love i loved a new song and then she was
singing this bit specifically so i think it like sticks with
a lot of people yeah it was so cute That's really cute.
I'm gonna cry.
Yeah.
Oh, miss this art.
I know.
So cute.
Yeah, this art is so nice.
Actually, we have a little, uh, a little thing about this
art.
Little thing.
Little thing about the art.
Yeah.
yeah so how many you guys are gonna be at offkaya so oh come
on oh you you little one have the chance to get a free
postcard with this beautiful art wow tell us more phoebe
chan chibi yeah and oh my back yeah you had this look of
like you were just like and then you just disappeared and
then disappeared and popped out of existence oh no oh yeah
you can get for free at the sets in a pro booth so come to
the sets in a pro booth at off god for free amazing wow wow
i crumbled under the pressure of my bad no don't worry
thanks for announcing yeah exciting stuff so if you love
this art get to the sets in a booth at off kite go go go go
go beautiful i genuinely yes so beautiful i love like the
little details like the the wings being like transparent and
it's still like cement over the back of them is so nice like
this is such nice yeah it's so nice
I talked about this a bit on stream but I don't I feel like
I've wrapped like twice in my life and then when we got it
they were like yes I envision Vicky doing the rap and I'm
like
you've been you've been assigned designated rapper thank you
thank you so much but you sound really cool yeah I was I was
kind of I love when you roll your R's.
Oh, thank you.
That's definitely the anchor practice.
Thanks, guys.
This is fun to film.
Yeah, this is so fun to film.
Yeah.
We are running back and forth.
And Mint, were you able to tell the the mold dungeon, the
spider mold dungeon story on your stream?
Oh, a little.
Yeah, I was able to tell.
talk about it yeah yeah were you guys able to talk about it
after it was so traumatic for you guys i haven't talked
about it with my therapist yet yeah
we can say for anybody that missed it though oh the the
puppets the puppets were filmed in a black mold spider
dungeon with uh water damage we like opened the door and i
could see the or like we could come out of them it was so oh
god it was it was a lot it just kept getting worse like
there was like a big puddle leading down into a dark
basement and we were like why is there a puddle going down
the stairs you have to go into this room that smelled real
bad luckily we had masks on we probably we still got
headaches i think we still got headaches later in the day
yeah it was like the strunhole I'm glad you weren't there
we could it would have downed all three of us it would have
there was black mold there was a mysterious bathroom where
the entire sink was plastic wrapped and it also in the door
like in the way of the door why was it plastic wrapped oh so
strange it was very strange place.
And then there was like a dehumidifier that was just filled
to the brim with water.
We were like, Steiner, why is there this weird bucket in the
corner?
And he's like, oh yeah, that's a, that's a dehumid, that's
like a dehumid, like it's like, it's supposed to be like
anti-liquid or something like that, but it was full of
liquid.
It's supposed to suck out the moisture in the air.
Yeah, exactly.
But they had, they had the the nerve to be like hey make
sure you clean up afterwards clean up what bro yeah what we
pulled out though we pulled out the green screen and uh a
bunch of spiders crawled out yeah yeah i did a wiggle to get
the spiders off thank you so much guys for your bravery so
actually so my puppet is actually mint hand is that Yeah.
Sorry, I was trying to, I feel like I should have, oh, I, I
wanted to puppeteer you better.
I apologize.
No, you did so good.
I was amazed.
So were you like, were you doing both of the puppets at the
same time?
That's so impressive.
She was doing both.
Jewel wielding the puppets.
It's like patting your head and rubbing your tummy.
It's so impressive.
So good.
Thank you very much.
Because at first we were like, oh, maybe Steiner can do the
third puppet.
But then, like, when we thought about it, only me and Mint's
hands fit in the puppet.
I see.
Actually, I don't even know if you would have been able to
fit in it.
I've got quite tall person hands.
I've got quite long fingers.
Yeah.
I was like, this is tough for me to get in.
Oh, wait, that's so true.
Yeah, because I put my hand up.
against your guys's before didn't i it was like so so sweet
this is so funny the running i'm not gonna lie like every
time oh every time i had to do this i really i am so sorry
don't worry as long as you're fine with appearing and
reappearing then that's
I'm glad I did not fall over here, guys.
I was like, don't fall over.
Don't fall over.
Yeah, you nailed it.
I was like, ow.
You guys can't tell, but Phoebe's actually dabbing there.
Yeah.
End of the proper dab, guys.
So good.
I was like, they're probably not going to be able to see it
when the sticker, when the sticker's on it.
So, yeah.
Might as well dab it up.
Yeah.
I mean, both of you were kind of dabbing it up.
I love this shot.
so good i know right oh makes me cry every time in toes or
chestcap you sung this show beautifully yeah it's so nice it
really feels love your emotion can i take five more minutes
the moving company is of course yes would you like me to we
have um you guys just keep going i'll just i'll just fall
asleep for a second okay are you sure okay sorry i'll be
right back yeah yeah no worries no worries okay all right by
the time she gets back we'll be in the i don't think we told
everybody we have we have slowly devolved versions of the
music video that we're going to be showing yeah be excited
guys we'll we'll continue when minto gets back because i
feel like i feel like we need to watch it with minto her
lovely In the meantime, Phoebe, would you like another
cursed marshmallow question?
Sure, or if you want to do one too, we could do one for you
as well.
Sure, let's do one.
Let's just don't look at it and just see what it is.
Okay, let's see what we got.
Oh my god.
Did we do this one before?
Did we?
Oh, which one was it?
It's about microwaved tea.
Why did the super cross the road?
To be free on the other side Didn't we do this one before?
I don't know.
I feel like maybe.
She put herself through it again.
We did do it.
You were a masochist.
Rise up Church of Apusirf.
Where are you at?
Church of Apusirf.
No, no, no, no.
Let's get rid of it.
Apusirf.
No Apusirf.
No.
No, no, no.
Ah-ah-ah...
Ah-ah-ah-ah.
Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah.
Ah-ah-ah.
Ah-ah-ah-ah.
Okay, bye guys.
No, no.
Alright, shall we get back to watching?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, sorry.
I thought you would keep...
No, I thought you guys would keep watching.
No, we want to watch your beautiful, She's actually this
part!
Yeah!
Let me go back to the beginning so we can hear it in all its
glory.
Oh no!
You're not alone, we're always here with you, Minto!
Yes!
Always!
Oh, it's so nice!
Oh, I have one more!
You want to talk a little bit about the footage here
actually?
Yeah, actually Minto took quite a bit of the stock footage
as well.
Yeah, I took these shots.
Just going around Akuba.
There's so many interesting things to see.
So honestly, you could just shoot your camera anywhere and
get something nice, I think.
So nice.
Yeah.
I like how that one you see Tokyo Dome and you're like,
wait, that's not Aki-bo.
But honestly, you guys have to understand that it was like
so cloudy and like icky for so long, so many of the days
that when like the sun came out, I was like just, I was
whipping out my camera for anything.
I was like, oh man.
I think it works because it's like on the Yamanote said on
the way to Aki-bo isn't it?
I think it works.
Really?
I was thinking also it's on our, it's us going on the way to
the quarry or something.
that makes sense you know in the music video we probably
also took the train to get there yeah exactly why is the
tokyo eye in me like but is that the right way that we'd be
riding the yamanode to get to the quarry from akihabura
actually i think you're right it's fine it's fine anyway
yeah and i was like i liked i wanted i liked the into the
sun i was like can you change that footage to zoom in on the
it felt it felt very like old anime old yeah wait this is
such a cute shot again i don't think i paused here before
it's nice to pause there's so many hidden like frames that
you might not notice unless you pause yeah oh we've got
someone in chat with a birthday happy birthday mr
mcflufflekins happy birthday Fluffle kings.
Half the board, they make fluffle kings.
Right, again, let me just set the record straight.
This is not what you say it is, okay, Jack?
I'm not having it.
What's with that face, then?
Listen, listen, listen.
Listen, it's just the heat from the explosion.
I'm like, oh my gosh, we gotta run, okay?
What?
How did they make this?
When did we get that shot?
That's a very good question.
We did not shoot that you guys.
We did not.
Yeah.
I'm guessing they added the legs on afterwards and didn't
actually like stand that.
That's cool though.
I don't remember.
It is very good.
So cool.
Seriously.
great editing oh my god yeah so apparently i accidentally
poked steiner in the eye here i'm so sorry i'm so sorry we
were just really getting into it wait is that why he puts
his hand to his face i think it was i think it was no i'm so
sorry steiner i'm sorry oh no i was how dare you us in the
black mold spider dungeon how dare you he booked it wait
this takes this takes a whole new meaning now that i know
he's not just face palming and he's like my eye ow
sometimes yes i love the finger lagging
oh cute so cute
He's like, yes, yes, I'm gonna become a changed man.
No, you won't.
The best part is...
And then we screamed when he first saw this.
Yeah!
It's so good.
Don't you love how this just kind of came out of nowhere
though?
I feel like we were filming and then suddenly like, okay,
now you're gonna explode him and we're like, huh?
Yeah.
I feel like that wasn't in the original plan, but anyway, it
was very...
I think I think originally he was supposed to have a redempt
like a proper redemption But we never got to film it.
So therefore This scene that was supposed to be a cute like
We exploded him for literally doing nothing like the guy
loitering The guy rubbed his hands together and was walking
He did a slow little dance in the corner You're like, I
don't like that.
This looks like Mint's become a chicken nugget or something
in this moment.
Delicious.
I love it.
It's so cute.
Yeah, the animation is the way, so let's appreciate these
dots.
Cute, me.
Cute.
A little cabbage!
Killed!
Cute, cute, cute, cute Cute, cute, cute So cute!
Good, cute!
So cute!
Ah, this shot is so cute!
I love the little teeth!
Oh my god, they're so sweet.
Um, I didn't mean to do that.
I'm sorry.
I love the way they animated your kate yeah it's really nice
right like the the cape physics yeah awesome i like this one
oh you look so cool stop stop stop right there mr
i need a visual degree asmr or something um why why do you
need that so that when i reach to get an cookie I can play
it and I will not get the extra cookie.
Tell me to go to the naughty step.
Phoebe Chan Cheeby you've already had five cookies today you
are absolutely not having another one go and sit on the
naughty step.
Oh yes ma'am yes ma'am yes ma'am what have you done wrong
what have you done wrong that you need to go the naughty
step.
I killed a man.
Whoa.
Mint Phantom, how dare you kill a man?
That is not very nice, is it?
Go to the naughty step.
And then Mint and I sitting on the naughty step and she's
like, what are you in here for?
I'm like, I almost, I almost, I'm like, what are you in here
for?
I killed a man.
The
punishment suits the crime same sentence very different
crimes yeah oh oh dear oh anyway to the naughty step i mean
i find guys the way that you find that i find time out
corner go okay can you guys okay i want you guys to tell me
to go the time out corner um what have i done um my dirty
keyboard then realistic.
It looks like I put in the timeout corner for a second.
Oh, no.
No, not the timeout.
No.
Can you still hear us?
I was in the timeout.
Yeah, I can hear you from the timeout corner.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
You can still hear us.
The timeout corner.
They're short.
Oh, so awesome.
I love all of it.
I particularly love mince, like, punch.
I'm just gonna say I love mince.
I feel like Monkey DeLuffy.
So good.
The Vicky smile is a very, very sweet Vicky smile.
It's so cute.
I didn't mean to spoil the night.
Vicky's about to do no good.
I know, right?
That's me about to purposefully put myself on the naughty
step.
That's my naughty step ready face.
I see you go into the cookie.
she's reaching up she's looking at you like I'm gonna take a
sixth I want to take a seventh oh
yeah okay so this is the best part best part I know who are
these people who are this how cool of us indiscriminately
sorry guys I accidentally went full screen oh oops I think
He got murdered twice!
What happened to him?
Oh my god.
They're taking out everybody who...
I don't know what their crimes are.
What?
Being buff.
This guy's like a footman, no?
Oh, being a foot?
What is he a foot?
No feet allowed!
No.
No children.
No feet.
No muscles.
wait wait then she is this grandma oh wait i must be honest
but at first when i saw the like the draft of this part i i
thought it was going to i thought this was a placeholder i
really i thought i thought i'm okay with it no i love it
it's so good i was kind of confused how it would be replaced
but But I'm impressed with everything.
Oh, Vicky, you can scroll frame by frame with, oh, you guys
know the secret tech, the shortcuts, man.
Whoa.
Apparently it said comma and something.
I don't really want to try it in case I accidentally do
something else, but I'm going to try it later.
Yeah, apparently it can.
Chat knows the tech.
This is the shot.
This is so nice.
Oh, special.
Guys, can we appreciate it?
I was like, go back, get it behind us.
Can we appreciate for how special it is and not keep
commenting on how much Mint is having to reach up?
Okay, look, I'm tall.
No one said that.
Plenty of people said that.
I don't think anyone said that.
I didn't see a single comment about that.
Well, my chat was saying it.
Damn, now we know what kind of slander goes.
on in the chat privately yeah the slander but no this is so
nice i love this shot oh so pretty how big were the step
stools in this shot shut up
i think the ground was slanted no i'm just kidding yeah no
maybe it was let's go with it was we were this was still
like the edge of the cliff though like we we could have
fallen we could have yeah oh my gosh that's so true actually
Yeah, we were actually very, very close to the edge of the
cliff.
We were very high up too.
I feel like we took, there was like another, like aside from
the video, we took this shot again, didn't we, or a similar
one out of the sunset, didn't we?
Was it, where was that?
Oh, Enoshima.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we did.
Yeah, so pretty.
Maybe we better Photoshop our faces, or the stickers onto
that one as well, so we can post that, because it was a nice
picture.
I want to post that one too.
Oh, so sweet.
Okay, I'm not necessarily going to be able to pause at every
credit, but I'm going to try.
Vocals, lyrics, live action, densest.exe, min, phantom,
Victoria, Roman, Phoebe, Chad.
I don't know why I'm clapping ourselves.
People continue to think that they're stand-ins, but they're
literally us.
On the short of my jump, people are like, wait, that's you
guys?
Like, yeah, we keep telling you.
Yeah.
We did it.
we are our own stunt actors we all yeah it was a lot of fun
lord loiter steiner thank you oh yeah oh yeah great job shad
great loitering shad director elv editing shad incredible
incredible and we have comments from uh lots of these people
in the credits actually after this so look forward to that
we have producer Julia
we are see this is the problem so fast wait it's so fast can
do the frame by frame I did it it's okay I've managed it we
have 2D animation evil crap and very moralia thank you I'm
so sorry if I say any song by the way thank you so much
thank you they did the like for example the stickers yeah
we'll get to see some of the stuff that they did and some
comments from them actually so look forward yeah um
illustration color script yui del thank you yo thank you uh
2d cleanup assistance nicholas paraguass thank you thank you
thank you secondary editing parfait operational guidebook
thank you so much thank you thank you i love that name i
know it's a great name um composition mixing mosaic wow
mosaic wow yeah yeah legend oh my god i'm doing my best guys
you're doing amazing there we go low bully animation studio
black patch let's go character models show afloat and just
pinky epic character models thank you yeah so cute animation
b moon flower liam toho and kolani thank you
Storyboards, Colani.
Thank you.
KUD, graphic, shaky, full of love.
And we are full of love for your work.
Thank you.
We are.
Character rigging, show up, flow, VFX and compositing,
compositing, compositing, that one.
Yeah.
Show up flow as well.
Environmental, model, and taste is Liam Toho.
Thank you.
much thank you thank you thank you everybody incredible team
storyboard we are
logo and motion graphic spirit snap thank you thank you
subtitles and kfx into weave productions joko and cloud 668
thank you thank you very nostalgic being cloud 667 Sorry,
um, anyway.
Um, uh, okay.
I like that it's Vicky making most of the six, seven jokes
now.
This is, this is like, this is refreshing.
Uh, oh yeah, each of our costuming.
Do we want each of our costumers each?
Dozo, dozo.
Minto.
Oh, mine was from Wet Rose Cosplay.
You
guys.
Nice quality.
Um, and I want to thank Stephanie.
Or so now ito in my chat from Romantic Serenade.
I love you so much.
Yubi!
And I want to thank my sweet friend Boba Fee, who worked on
my costuming on a very tight deadline.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Um, oh my god.
So fast.
Okay, hang on.
Ah!
I keep going full screen.
Sorry.
screaming every time I do I don't need to scream all right
okay right right okay you got this yeah on-site director
wait who's that who is that Andrew I'm buying and Andrew
some guy named Andrew thank you so much to some guy named
Andrew thank you so much thank you assistant director
Richard S Cam thank you lucky thank you i love you camera
walker raymond yeah yeah oh one more oh i can do it yeah
video production and footage assist co-limited thank you
thank you thank you photography art of resistances thank you
so much thank you Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
And finally, project coordination.
Setup Japan Co-Limited!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Honestly, just so, so grateful.
So hecking grateful, you know?
So, so grateful.
How do you guys feel watching it again together?
It's so special.
It is!
I'm so far, and I can't believe it actually happened.
and we pulled that off.
And it ended up being even better than we could, but then we
had Imagine at first.
Yeah.
Which was already really, really cool because we're doing
explosions.
I had my doubts for a little bit, but it all happened.
I was like, dang, this is awesome.
It was so, so good.
Only because there's so many incredible people that came
together.
Creative and talented and hardworking, wonderful people.
Thank you so much, the entire team.
and you guys wow we we did it we did it we did it
oh no it was such a like you know i think in in the moment
it was like next shot next shot get it done you know at the
quarry and stuff but i really wanted to just appreciate
every moment of it because when you think back on it's like
genuinely such an amazing special experience that we got to
do isn't it like right like you know not a lot of people
People can say they filmed at the Tokusatsu Quarry and were
able to do such awesome things, such awesome explosions and
things.
So I just really, I don't know, I wanted to take in every
moment while I was there, you know?
Yeah.
Phoebe?
Yes.
Okay, you are there.
Okay.
I am here in the room.
All right.
Guys, are we ready to see some behind the scenes?
I know you guys are very interested in this kind of stuff so
um are we doing a particular order now I'm just I'm just
gonna vibe are we cool with that are we cool to just go in
whatever order I think that's probably good okay right then
let's go in the order that I have here we will start with
the amazing show of flow show of flow behind the scenes so
give me a little second we have what was that wait let me
let me turn off studio mode for you guys so you can see it a
bit better so we have some behind the scenes images from
show of flow who were in charge of the the low poly low poly
some of the low poly animation stuff we have uh this amazing
image um what do we think of what do we think of this image
guys amazing just like we said do we have any comments any
uh yeah i think it's it's pretty pretty beautiful honestly
um let me see uh we have some other ones as well that i can
show you um give me a second we have this lovely lovely
image we also have lovely image phoebe are you there before
i show this image i'm there okay oh yeah i guess i'm not
there oh my god okay oh but yeah yeah i'm i'm there
technically oh my god phoebe when her model disconnects
wait so so what are the context behind these um there is no
i have not been given any context I am just showing them as
they are.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
All right.
So we just have a grumpy, grumpy Phoebe is the name of this
file.
How do we feel?
How do we feel about grumpy Phoebe?
Pretty cute, right?
I love it.
But also that is definitely when my model disconnects like
Vince said.
Definitely.
I want this as a reaction image, honestly.
We also have two sides.
of the same mint I'm like a frog whoa what what is going on
here I'm trying to work it out I don't really know sometimes
in 3d you have to get really creative with like mouths
because you know how like anime mouths they turn to the side
you know and like uh you want that like oh I'm talking but
I'm looking to the side but my mouth is on the side kind of
thing Narahodo, Narahodo.
Well, I think it's that kind of thing.
Yeah, I think so.
And it could be.
Oh, maybe it's like the side mouth for your, yeah, the shot
where you're from the side where you do your little smile.
It could be.
Also have this.
This is cute.
It's very cute.
Oh, it looks so...
I look deranged a little bit.
I love it.
It's so cute.
First time seeing these, by the way, you guys.
I'm the only one who has seen any of these.
So this is fresh reactions from the kids.
Very cute.
I feel like you're giving cat energy.
I don't know how to explain it.
Do you know what I mean?
No, I think I get it.
Very cute.
It's very, very cute.
Very cat.
So reference image was, what's her name from Lucky Star?
She has that program.
Oh.
The one who sings Enka The one with the pink hair Yes, yes,
yes The name has flown from my brain But I know who you mean
Yeah No, that is very, very the style Wait, Konata?
No The pink gal with the TV show Oh, the pink, oh, her, yeah
Yeah, yeah Who sings Enka Yeah, yeah I love this kind of
stuff, guys Look at this This is so cool So this is like I
think it's when minute doing the punch but to get the hand
like it's like crazy i bet you're loopy before what are your
legs doing so good it's 3d movie magic wow yeah we got some
i'm calling it the movie magic in the back such a long arms
guys wow wait the gun Another shot of me with long arms for
the Vicky Punch.
I don't know what is going on with my other arm.
Whoa.
The Vicky Missile.
Yeah.
Wow.
I like how the lines, the like, you know, the 3D lines look
like they're motion lines for you.
Yeah, it does, actually.
Oh my gosh.
So cool.
It's really awesome to see these kind of like...
behind the scenes type things isn't it oh this is the hud so
all of our different little player things how cute infinite
time we did debate whether steiner should be liquid steiner
because steiner was like i don't want my name to be i don't
want to he said he was like i don't want to distract from
the girls i don't know what he means by that yeah what what
does he mean
by that Phoebe she's going to ask what do you mean by that
style she was like what do you mean by that and then these
are I think the cute little the cute little buttons oh cute
yeah for the secret combo so cute and then we actually have
some videos as well from from Show a Flow, so let me show
those as well.
I think this is where Steiner is a block.
He's been reduced to a shape.
This is actually how I do things, guys.
Yeah.
Easy peasy.
This was the real fight scene.
The other one was the fake one.
This is the real one.
This is what happened.
Yeah.
It's so cute and then we also have I don't know what this is
Oh, I don't know what
Are they gonna put the hair back on or no?
No, okay, they're just gonna keep it off.
No, no, no All right, I like how the ribbon is just like not
attached as well
That's what the dance should do
oh oh baby you cut out you keep cutting out oh i think it's
getting worse no it is yeah now her sounds cutting out too
it wasn't doing that before is it getting increasingly bad
oh your sound cut out for a sec there yeah unfortunately can
you still see the stream phoebe am i good to keep
I'm so sorry.
Oh, don't worry.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
If you can hear us.
Can you hear us?
Oh.
I want to wait to show the next video until Phoebe can see
it.
Because it's funny.
Follow Phoebe.
Phoebe.
Oh.
Can you hear us, Phoebe?
I can.
I can hear you now.
Oh, he brought me back.
He brought me back somehow.
Okay.
Next video.
Roman in her natural habitat.
Imagine you see that flying in the wild.
You see that above the forest line.
That's crazy.
So cool.
And we actually have comments from people at Show of Flow.
Very, very kind.
indeed so let me let me get the comments up so i can show
you guys what they said thank you so much for your amazing
work you guys seriously incredible stuff okay give me a
second let's read their comments okay uh hey when we were
offered the low poly segment it was a surprise The warm
reception to the burn-on MV has been so amazing.
Julia and Setsna were great to work with.
The girls were such fun personalities to depict.
And playing with the Tokusatsu theming was great for us.
From Show of Flow.
Oh, thank you, Show of Flow.
So nice.
I think we might have like several comments from them
actually.
So let's have a look.
very stylized so sometimes it was necessary to break the
models in ways that only look right from the camera's
perspective which we've just seen yeah yeah so cool yeah
that's so crazy actual movie magic
mint is so fun love made with renders i made of mint Vicky
and Phoebe, included some intricate details that got
obliterated when we scaled them down to standard definition
for the video.
Oh, we're sorry.
Oopsie.
So nice.
And then we saw the HUD stuff.
Cute.
Very cool.
So cute.
Oh, I'm so good.
When does the fighting game win?
Honestly.
Oh, my God.
The grumpy Phoebe is still my favorite.
We need a Vicky one.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we need a Chris Vicky.
Yeah.
Can make it like a stamp in the Discord.
I think that would be amazing.
The gang and I at Studio Black Patch would work with Densers
EXE again in a heartbeat.
Thank you all for a great experience and happy 100k.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We're so incredibly grateful for everything.
that you have done for us so thank you so much that was that
was show of flow okay next up pog and i don't mean i don't
mean pog in general i mean i mean also pog in general um but
i mean pog who did the ending puppet scene where the puppets
uh blow everything up yeah yeah yeah Yeah.
All right.
Oh, Phoebe, can you hear us?
Oh, no.
She's frozen.
Should I keep going or should I wait?
I don't know.
I feel like you should.
I feel like you should just keep going.
We've got quite a lot to do.
Look at it.
I feel like I feel like you should just.
Yeah, just keep going.
I'm doing my best.
You know what?
I might open up the stream on my phone on data.
and then like maybe that'll I can at least watch I wonder if
you join if you joined the call via data maybe that would be
oh yeah true true because the model's not as we can just
hear you that's the main thing and then everyone's going to
be like an Xbox mic okay I'm going to do it though I'm going
to join the call from my experience it's like a treat to
have a bit of Xbox mic chat quite enjoy it yeah okay here we
go then least scratch of the ears yeah okay okay xbox mic is
more exciting yeah because i had to be on like an xbox mic
when i went back to the uk recently and chat were like
where's the xbox mic gone we want it back so wow they're so
needy yeah i know i know hello do you hear me yes oh god is
it loud now We can hear you.
Cool.
Hey.
Alright, I'm going to turn you down a little bit, though,
maybe.
I'm just going to think.
Okay.
What if we all join the Xbox mic?
That'd be so funny.
Yeah, maybe I should get out my Xbox mic as well.
Yeah, I'll join the Discord.
So this is Polk, who did the ending puppets.
first of all wish you were here
that's so cute wish you were here getting blown up exploded
by Phoebe I mean guys would you go on this holiday would you
go on this little vacation to get exploded by Phoebe let us
know of course yeah very beautiful and then we also have a
part of the ending scene as well which i believe has sound
actually so i think this is one of the ones that has the
original uh demo that phoebe recorded actually oh yeah all
right wake up to the right to the future rise up because
we're stronger than ever raise up and light's mightier than
the soul um wait what was that wait what was that I'm sorry,
replay it again.
Yeah, this is what we got, and so of course, we're kind of
like, is this the final version?
I mean, if we didn't ever get that!
No, no, I don't remember Thanos ever.
I remember Thanos throwing it back, but...
actually what if he was behind the music video like the
entire time maybe maybe he was and we'd never know we never
knew wow that's crazy guys yeah yeah the layers and we have
some let me turn the bgm back on we have some comments
actually from the team so let me uh let me get those loaded
up give me a second you're sure from the pog team thank you
so much just wanted to leave a short message congratulating
everyone on such a unique and cool project coming together
even though all the issues and unexpected moments throughout
the way it came out so well and it's honestly one of the
coolest projects that come out recently and I'm glad it
could throw a little bit of my chaos into the ending to help
tie things together I honestly think it was the perfect
ending to the music video.
I really do.
I think so too.
Yeah.
Big.
Thank you, Pog.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you, Pog.
I thought it brought it together beautifully.
Absolutely beautifully.
Yes.
Alright, guys.
So exciting and we get to see all this stuff.
Well, you guys are, I mean, I'm kind of seeing it for the
first time because I only vaguely looked at it, but you guys
are really seeing it for the very first time.
So it's all very exciting.
Okay.
We're going to start with some of the uh so this is very
frap and very who worked on the animation frap and very who
worked on the animation um so here we've got uh phoebe and
then a bit of minto at the bottom there and the different
expressions very cute very so cute when we got the like when
we got the set day basically
be depicted in the 2d animations i was like wow this is so
us what wow it's so cute hello it's so cute right they're so
cute i love the art style so much so cute um oh my god you
guys you guys aren't even ready you guys aren't even ready
for the next image it's so cute wait i feel like phoebe in
particular is gonna i don't know why i just particularly
think phoebe will enjoy this
Look at little, little, little dead sets.
They're so, they're so beautiful.
They're so beautiful.
Tiny, tiny.
So, so red.
I don't know why they're naked.
Come to think of it, why are we naked?
Anyone?
I want to get merch of this somehow.
on pillow you know how like you can do like flat pillows and
stuff and like we look like shin chans yeah looks like i'm
about to turn around if we can't run away what dress up
dolls made with this style oh wait that'd be so cute yeah
like you'll put little clothes on them oh that'd be so cute
i don't want clothes just show my butt
I don't think that's true, chat.
What?
Chat said that you and Phoebe are that size IRL.
Rude!
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I've laughed a million times.
This one is so cute.
I actually love this art.
It's so cute.
Look at this.
So beautiful.
Again, why are we naked?
We will answer that question some other time.
I don't know what the answer is.
But we're in our streaking era or something.
Yeah, I guess so.
I think that's illegal, so we probably shouldn't do that.
But very cute artwork.
I love how the expressions are different on everyone as
well.
So cute.
I do like how we all have the Studio Ghibli blush.
Yeah.
You're like, you know, the...
Oh, God.
Onsen Senior, it could be, actually.
This is us having one onsen time, onsen episode.
Yeah.
We have some videos as well, but hopefully...
Oh, Phoebe, you can see everything, right?
I can, I can.
Okay.
Then let's watch.
Did these have sound?
I don't think they did.
If they do, then I'll...
Oh, no, they didn't.
Yeah, look at this.
It's like the different...
of the video.
Wow.
The transformation.
It's so interesting to see this process.
Wow.
So cool.
I love the little hair tuck behind the ears.
So cute.
Thank you.
Yeah, I love that.
It's so sweet.
I love it.
So sweet.
Ninja expression is very, very cute too.
Yes, so cute.
but cute at the same time i like it it's very cute i like it
can i just say that the way that frapp and very depicted me
is my favorite my personally my favorite way that i've ever
been drawn ever it's so like jibbly protagonist i don't know
it just it feels very i felt very i felt my own spirit being
put into it i like i like it very much i totally get it
though they really like embodied our personalities you know
like it didn't no point in the animation felt like that
doesn't feel like vicky or mental phoebe all very much like
felt so consistent to like our personalities and how we move
and stuff so i really liked that they clearly like paid a
lot of attention to that so yeah it's really nice um this
one as well the not the scene where i'm not doing what you
guys said i'm doing very nice oh it's so interesting how
it's definitely not far like does it start pink and then
they overlay with like all the colors how does it work does
anyone know right i've always wondered that because you see
that in like lots of work in progress animations like sakuga
stuff as well it's i'm like oh yeah i like uh you see
vicky's expression change too it's cute yeah it's so cute
yeah wow just tensai such tensai oh is this one for the
again wow oh it's so cool like every time it turns around it
gets more detailed wait that's crazy
the lighting for this one is so sick too so pretty the stick
man level is crazy like i didn't know it was that you know
it starts off like that that's so cool wow so cool yeah and
the way that they really made it like the like the roses
shining up at us you know like the way they did the lighting
so pretty oh so nice thank you so much to frapp and very and
we've got some comments from them as well so give me a
second um sorry guys i'm like a bit slow today but i'm doing
my best to make sure i don't make any mistakes i love
everything yeah no don't worry about all right and i think
these are in order okay there okay let's read their comments
hi everyone i was one of the 2d animators for the burn on mv
thank you all so much for watching i can't even tell you
what a joy it was to work on this project one of the most
fun and chaotic moments or months of my career and i had a
blast the whole way oh that makes me so happy oh thank you
it was chaotic thank you much we love your work rap and i
spent our work time together either on discord calls or
separately tuning in to your guys's streams to keep us
company while we wait that's so cute what the heck
not only was i humming burn on in my household for the
entire month but you girls that just started showing up in
my dream wow whoa i mean i guess that makes sense if you're
like working non-stop on something right it's bound to
influence your subconscious in that way yeah we were just
showing up and saying gumbat there you can do it hopefully
hopefully we weren't being annoying in the dream no we were
we were slave drivers we were like work yeah work yeah go
yeah it's been forever dream to work on idle animations and
mvs specifically I'm a huge Idol master fan Rika P forever
and so to get the opportunity to animate Incredible choreo
draw those wonderfully frilly dresses and lip sync to this
fantastic song.
It was a dream come true It was a dream come true for us to
have you working on it.
Yeah By the way, can you guys see we'll be able to work
together more and more Yeah, I hope so can you guys see the
the thing can you read it if i'm sharing i feel bad like
reading all of them if you guys want to read some of them
but i don't know if you can read them i can't read yeah let
me let me try and if i put it like if i put it like that can
you read it or still no oh yeah i can read now okay do you
want to read it yeah if one of you guys wants to read i feel
bad reading all of them dozo
oh i oh i can read this one uh throw in the fact that we got
to animate a crap ton of explosions It was literally the
perfect project.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
And then...
Oh.
Go ahead.
No, though.
It says, thank you to Julia, who gave us the ideal mix of
support, structure, and freedom throughout the whole
process.
Chad, who did immaculate work, bringing everything together
in the edits, and to all the folks who stayed up for those
long nights working to make something truly magical.
I think people became friends because of this.
i think some of these i think some of the wonderful team
members ended up actually like bonding over these late
nights drama bond i was not gonna say it but yeah i feel bad
i'm sorry guys it had to stay up so late and stuff but wowed
was it did it pay off such a beautiful beautiful mv oh thank
you so much um and of course to the girls this project meant
a lot so thank you Thank you from the bottom of my heart for
trusting us.
The pen light is truly mightier than the sword.
All my love and more.
Oh, Barry, thank you.
Thank you, Barry.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
As a bonus, here are some early drawings, which are the ones
we just saw.
So, so pretty.
So, so cute.
And baby dancing.
sets baby then sets god's better uh this is from frapp
someone like to read the message from frapp sure uh hi
everyone thank you so much for giving us the opportunity to
animate for you after a very intense and exciting month of
work, we're done.
Yay!
Do you want to do this one, Minto?
Oh, okay.
Originally, our editor, Shad, had pitched Viri and I a
handful of shots to animate.
Almost all of them were still frames with very little
animation as there was a tight deadline, and Shad didn't
want to put too much pressure on us.
Thanks, Shad.
Aw!
After our meeting, Viri and I had a sort of, are you
thinking what I'm thinking moment and decide we would rather
go all out and animate as much as we possibly could within
our one month's death.
Oh, you guys!
Oh, people working so hard for us.
Thank you so much.
You guys are awesome.
which as a result is what you see in the current mv it was a
lot of stress a lot of work but a project like this is
exactly what she and i want to work on so a lot of passion
was put into the mv on our end we could tell i hope that
everyone enjoyed it we could we loved it and finally and i'd
especially like to thank producer julia for believing in us
there were many points during production where i wasn't sure
if we'd finish but she seemed to have faith in us Thank you
everyone for your hard work.
Aww.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
These 2D animated bits really like were so exciting to see
come together.
I didn't even realize how elaborate it was going to end up
being either because we also knew that the deadlines were
really tight too.
going all out and gosh i hope that we can work together with
all these wonderful artists more in the future with with
like less crazy deadlines for sure it was very down to the
wire so everybody was pulling lots of lots of work late
nights and everything those stuff thank you everybody so so
much thank you guys are the best oh go ahead oh go ahead go
ahead go ahead i was just gonna say it's it's something that
only i could imagine my wildest dreams to have like so many
different elements including like full 2D animation in a
video, in a music video with my girls so yeah, I'm just so
hecking grateful thank you so much Frap and very what were
you gonna say Phoebe?
Go ahead.
I was just gonna say that like it really was like I think we
we did the final review of the final render of the music
video on the screen of our stream our anniversary our six
month anniversary in that day okay that's why it took a
little while to start stream today as well why I was late
because I was just like putting all the stuff in but anyway
but I'm so grateful that we have so much so much
behind-the-scenes content to show you guys like really
really makes me happy that everyone not only took the time
to get our MV done in time but also took the time to make
all of this behind-the-scenes stuff for the stream today so
honestly thank you so much it's so interesting to be able to
see the yeah thank you all right you guys so that was frapp
and very uh next up we're gonna look at some stuff from
spirit snare who did the logo here are the logos we've got
some behind the scenes from the i was about to say i was
about to say yolo that's absolutely not the right word the
yolo
exciting so this is the like render of the building i think
in the in the background of of the logo i guess it's akiba
probably yeah yeah so cool oh is it meant to be like the you
know you can see the train line like running through the um
there's a train like the above train line yeah because it's
quite a i think this is the view from the bridge yeah so
cool very awesome um so we have that uh give me a second we
have did where did these get used to the i'm not sure but i
love them oh oh i think yeah this was when it was showing us
like in our costume like yeah say fuku and stuff yeah yeah
yeah so these are different variations i guess it was the
bottom one that was picked in the end but i like the other
ones as well yeah very cool thank you so much for the very
sweet of you thank you so much thank you thank you we have
this original version of the logo as well whoa it's burning
i can feel the heat coming off it pretty cool it's very like
i would definitely see this as the logo of an actual like
tokusatsu show yeah yeah yeah so cool no yeah i genuinely
like it felt like that didn't it when i saw the i was like
yes that's perfect absolutely right peak there's a lot of
research that was done to make it authentic yeah i think so
someone's in minecraft what minecraft it kind of does look
like the minecraft logo oh yeah perfect yeah that's that's
what we want that's what we want um we have comments as well
um oh a lot of kind comments a lot of kind comments from
spirit snare um let's have a look i've never done anything
this hot blooded and justice packed yeah justice justice
against loiterers before so before i started all of the 3d
work i hopped into illustrator and did some quick ideation
oh wow i mean it's already like coming together just from
that initial oh you guys sorry sorry sorry sorry let me go
to it's already like looking kind of like it even from that
yeah yeah i love the like the tilt of the the framing of the
letters and everything so cool i feel like it was already
coming together at that point isn't it uh go phoebe do you
want to read it dozo yeah it um despite julie giving me a
bunch of install for an actual tokusatsu series i ended up
pulling from a different one robo me from brendler thank you
yo thank you robot phoebe thank you so thank you robot
phoebe thank you thank you phoebe.exe for that kind reading
it's perfect i feel like the robo phoebe kind of fits the
whole like tokusatsu uh theming you know oh yeah yeah
talking about character named robo me yeah exactly it's
perfect dozo minto the first drafts kind of fall between
robo me with the classic red gold double stroke and low-key
monk oh the super blocky text you were right you were right
oh my god oh my gosh oh that's so cool and it's like the
different iterations of the text very awesome originally i
wanted to give the actual letter forms flames but when i put
them into after effects the bevels started clipping into
each other uh-oh are we gonna see what that looks like in
the next thing oh but that's pretty cool though what they
end up with i feel like you want to wait this one yeah do
can you if you can i i will try oh yeah i was forced And to
put the flames directly onto the surface of the lighter
instead, I think it ended up looking pretty sick.
It didn't!
No!
It looks so good.
All right.
Yeah, I love it.
It's so good.
Oh!
Yeah!
For these, they were designed to be super campy toy box call
outs.
Oh, I look so good!
And then we got the different variations.
This is the one they went with in the end.
very nice while this was going for a we could only digitally
type set hell vetica back then sort of 90s vibes oh so it
was like accurate to the time that we were kind of placing
the mv in that's pretty cool wasn't very nice attention to
detail yeah dozo febu
uh i'll read it i'll read it so the skyline is part of the
logo oh dozo dozo dozo dozo dozo we can eat now we can eat
now I was asked to include the Akiba skyline as part of the
logo And it took me a while for me to figure out what kind
of angle of Akiba I wanted That would give at least some
sort of Akiba vibes without it looking too generic Also, we
might be able to find out what they were going for Because
we think we think we know we think we know where it is
You're right!
Yeah, this is the intersection in front of Manse-Bashi
Bridge!
The bridge heading towards Kanda, looking towards the dead
center of Chiodori!
That's so cool.
It's so iconic, isn't it?
So, makes sense.
Yeah, the JR train track bridge is what I thought.
Yeah, I think the tel-tel side is big.
Akiba, the escalators on the Manikineko Gigo Akiba 2
building and the JR train track bridge.
I don't live in Japan, so thank you Street View.
No, no, you did perfect!
Yeah, we could tell.
We could tell.
Yeah, it was very Wakari-Yasui.
Yes.
All right.
Who wants to read their comment?
I can read it.
I think we're just going in order, right?
Yeah, I can't remember the order I've already forgotten.
Very not.
Wait.
Sorry.
Well, who just went?
I don't remember.
I don't know.
It's you, Phoebe.
It's you.
Thank you, Minta.
Keep in track.
Yeah.
Me?
Okay.
Colonel.
It's definitely one of the things I've ever done, even when
I was watching the animatic.
Yeah, I knew it was going to be something truly special.
I'm grateful to the team for having me on.
I'm grateful to all the Denshi who enjoyed the final
product.
Fighting on!
Oh, that's so nice.
I tried not to laugh at this lovely comment because it's a
very sweet comment.
Oh, thank you so much, Spirit Snap.
Wait, you're so sorry, I'm like...
No, don't worry, Phoebe.
It's funny.
don't worry don't worry thank you so much for your lovely
comments spirits nan for your great work oh and one last
thing oh oh my god whoa can you guys see look it's it's it's
congrats on 100k in the logo.
Whoa.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, what was that?
That was aggressive.
I'm enjoying that the model is now moving and her voice is
like that.
So it's just like, this is just how Phoebe speaks.
Yes.
Very nice.
Thank you so much.
thank you all right give me one second you guys so that was
the amazing spirit snare next up we have Yui Dell who did
the the amazing um the amazing art the in the the bit you
know you know the bit you know the bit you're that bit yeah
the one you can get a free postcard of if you go to the sets
and a booth at our Okay, so we've got, like, a progress
thing, actually.
So this is Draft 1.
Phoebe looking very pretty into Draft 2.
Wow.
It's so cool to see, like, the details.
Yeah, different lighting and seeing the details as they're
being added is so cool.
I don't know if this is intentional.
It feels like it's going to, like, different times of day.
It feels like it was, like, sunrise.
Yeah, I think it is.
Oh, is that what it's meant to be doing?
I think so.
Wow, amazing.
So that's very cool.
So beautiful.
Is it like actually...
Is it painted or is it using like painted brushes, I wonder?
It looks like it's like painted like on a canvas.
So pretty.
Oh, look at this, guys.
It's so nice.
These are the color scripts, I think.
Oh.
Oh!
Frame by frame.
Wow!
It's so good.
Oh, hang on.
Let's make this one a little bit bigger.
So pretty!
Um...
Oh, sorry.
Wrong one.
This one.
Whoa!
That's so cool.
Oh!
It is a master of fallen lighting.
Artists are magical, aren't they?
I know.
Like, the way they can do stuff like this.
Oh, incredible stuff.
There is also...
I think it's my hand.
And a Game Boy as well.
Oh, Game Boy.
What is this from?
Yeah, that's what I was wondering.
Yeah, what is this from?
Was it in the video?
It's a secret...
Was it used for the secret combo?
Yeah, maybe.
I mean, maybe...
It's my hand, because it's got my glove.
But I don't know where...
Yeah.
I guess some behind the scenes.
Yeah, behind the scenes stuff.
And then...
I think that's everything, is it?
No, maybe not.
Hang on.
What are these ones?
Oh, are these the final?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Final art.
Oh, this was supposed to be used.
in the screen shattering effect oh wait okay hold on then
steiner sent a message and it had it uh we just got a
clarification oh yeah that it was supposed to be used in the
screen shattering effect for the secret combo ah interesting
because we did have a different like we had something
envisioned for that secret combo section that was only going
to be in the music video and not in like the studio version
of the song.
But it ended up not working out.
So I think it was going to be used for that.
Oh, that thing.
Right, right, right, right.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah.
So we were thinking of what were we thinking of?
We were thinking of having like a fade out or something,
weren't we at one point.
Yeah.
We didn't go through with it in the end because we were
like, is this going to make sense?
Yeah.
Yeah, it was a little hard to implement with how much time
we had.
to get the video out.
But yeah, there's going to be like a fade out slash like
fade to black and like the music was going to become muffled
during the secret combo as someone was going to be inputting
it.
There's going to be button sounds for actually inputting the
secret combo.
And then the music was going to come back in suddenly.
But we could not implement that in time.
But I loved the way that it ended up in the end.
Honestly, I think it was the best outcome.
And then, yeah, I think these are...
Are there two variations that you can get at Offkai then?
I think that's what this is implying.
It seems to be like the night version and the sunset
version.
So, gotta catch them all, I think.
I might be lying.
We'll find out.
Oh, no.
Yep, we just got confirmation.
Yes, there are two variations.
Okay, two variations.
We've got this, like, nighttime mode, and then the one we
just had on screen, the kind of sunset mode.
It's so beautiful.
So, yeah, guys, if you're able to pick up one of those
postcards, so.
All right, then we've got some comments from Yui Dale, so
let me just get those loaded up.
Yosh, yosh, yosh, yosh, yosh, yosh.
Okay, comment.
Honestly, this whole experience felt so surreal.
It was one of the shortest projects I've been on, but also
one of the most rewarding.
The whole team was so lovely to work with, and just
interacting with each other gave We surges of motivation
better than any energy drink.
That's so nice.
That is so nice.
I hope people made friends through this project, you know?
I've heard they were all on call with each other and
discussing things, so hopefully they all had a fun time
working on it.
Yeah.
Wait, what happened?
Cool, look at what?
It's Tiders sent in the Discord.
What?
He forwarded a message, I guess, from the...
Um...
I see.
Give me a second.
I feel like this needs context.
I see.
The true...
Yeah.
Everyone deserves to see this.
Okay.
Give me a second.
Who made this?
Who did this?
Okay, guys.
Look, this is the true...
The true meaning behind the Game Boy.
This is really what it was.
This is what it was.
Flame Nani was Zuni.
Of course it's that guy.
That's what's on my Game Boy, guys.
I have been called out.
Very nice.
That's beautiful.
I wish.
I don't think I ever...
I don't think I ever had this Game Boy, actually.
I think, I don't think I ever had this one.
Oh.
I'm not, I don't think.
No, it's, you literally have it in your hands right now.
Yeah, yeah, I don't have it in my hands.
Yeah, it's one of your favorite games.
Yeah, yeah.
Is it like cookie clicker, but you keep pressing the button
and it makes some keys?
Yeah.
That sounds like a great game.
Can somebody make that?
That'd be great.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Sonic X, Shadow Generation.
I think that game's not quite what you're, thinking it is
actually um the whole experience for okay yeah yeah better
than i like that comment better than any energy drink that's
so fun i love that they got energy from from just yeah i
don't know working with each other that's so nice um febby
do you want to read this one yeah i would totally do this
all over again if it meant working with the same lovely
lovely team i think they did become friends oh so nice thank
you julia and shabby for kidnapping me and guiding me and
thank you frap and viri for trusting me with those color
scripts oh it's so nice i love that they loved that they
became friends pretty yeah seeing them side by side is nice
yeah color drafts color drafts for those who don't know
color scripts are guides for the animators that map out the
color mood and lighting oh Okay, no, I don't really know
much about that kind of...
I don't really know much about how 2D animation pipeline
works at all, to be honest, so it's very interesting to see.
Yeah, right.
I basically handed these off along with color sets, which
indicate what color goes where.
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
Over to Frap and Ferry and prayed for them day and night.
They did an amazing job.
of examples oh that's so cool cool so what we saw earlier
you want to read this one mint i can't see it i'm sorry it's
so small oh sorry oh thank you huge thank you to phoebe
vicky and mint as well and everyone who is involved this was
such a labor of love and i feel so lucky i was able to be a
part of it and thank you to everyone who watched and enjoyed
oh it's so cute viewers like you Thank you so much, yeah.
It's because you guys, you know, it's so nice to see this
project that everyone put so much effort and love into.
That you guys love it so much as well.
So thank you for your comments, your views and sharing it
with people.
Thank you.
Um, alright.
Uh, let's go back to singing.
And then, uh, Dunay.
Also, I'm trying so hard to rejoin with my model.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, take your time.
Don't worry about it.
We have some very fun videos from Shad that I think you guys
will enjoy coming up next.
So let's view those, shall we?
Oh, no!
I mean, it looks like this for a really long time, not gonna
lie.
Literally JoJo.
Amazing.
Wow.
Incredible.
I had to watch it again because it was just so funny.
So funny.
all right and then we also have i think some of them shad
voiced themselves come on the secret combo yeah hurry up
yeah but you're supposed to do it you think you're better
than me what if i am saying that come on just do the secret
combo right hurry up do it then yeah but you're supposed to
do what you think you're better than me what if i am saying
that come on just do the secret combo yeah hurry up do it
yeah but you're supposed to do what you think you're better
than me what if i am too good i love it let me do it just
give me the control she's gonna get away just give me the
freaking thing let me do the video voiced by shad please can
we request that now we need to do the dub that's incredible
absolutely incredible stuff And we have a comment from Shad
as well.
Give me a second.
Uchop.
Uh, wait, this feels like...
This doesn't feel like the first...
And...
Okay, well, sorry.
This is the order I've received them in.
So if this is not the right order, I'm sorry.
anyways um and and what and i think i especially like to
thank producer julia or believing in us oh this is from
frapp oh hang on just a minute there he said go one over
they said go one over yeah i don't know why this is to be
fair guys this was in the folder i'm sorry there we go oh
here we go all right okay this project was far and away the
most chaotic and the most fun i've had in my editing career
even now i don't think it's fully set in with me that this
is real lmao working on a big project like this and getting
to bounce ideas back and forth with so many wonderful people
made me feel so alive and i'd a thousand percent love to do
more stuff like this in the future maybe without the crunchy
i was so sorry sorry that it was such a a time crunch for
you guys Yeah.
Aww.
It makes me so happy.
I mean, it goes to show how incredible everyone is because
they were able to put something out of this caliber, like,
in this time crunch, but also a mad intention for when
they're not, they're not, like, tethered down to the limits
of time, you know.
Yeah.
It's actually incredible, like, how much the whole team
managed to do in such a short period of time.
Actually, it's crazy.
yeah thank you so much okay let me uh hopefully this one's
the right one i hope so it seems like it see if you'd like
to read this one uh okay you see okay baby vicky meant thank
you all so much for trusting me with putting together the mv
and thank you so much for the words of encouragement and
praise it's genuine linking my fuel we meant every word we
love you and we love your work huge huge shout outs to julia
very frapp and yumi del for being on the ground floor as we
put this MV together messaging through the late nights.
Yes, thank you.
I love this single one of you guys.
Thank you.
Such sweet and lovely people.
And Dane?
Minto, would you like to read this one?
Everyone works so hard on this, so please be sure to give
them their flowers.
They made all this happen.
Thank you so much for the love you gave to the MV.
Thank you.
I wish we could send everyone a big bouquet of flowers a
thank you yes yeah oh thank you so much um we cannot send a
bouquet of flowers but we can say how thankful we are so
thank you we truly appreciate it so much from the bottom of
our hearts we do we do we do thank you so much um okay Do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do do do you know what is this We have some behind
the scenes called I think it's called Steiner's torment
Let's find out about it.
Here we go what is this I'm gonna fucking die I'm gonna
fucking die bro I'm
gonna fucking more we have more that came from apparently oh
boy oh boy oh god i don't like this angle what is this i
don't even know what i'm doing these fans are so wrinkly at
this point like this is the worst fucking job we get like
what's even the point is just like a pair of baby pants
what is he doing why is oh what look at you i don't think it
i don't know why do you iron your pants like i'm looking i'm
looking getting a little a little annoyed because it's hot
in this what is he getting annoyed what's wrong i'm not the
original okay that's a little bit don't get annoyed but i
still know how i got the actual shot here is meant to be
like I'm not seeing the vision.
How long is this face?
Are these coins?
There's coins on the floor.
Clean your room and iron your trousers, Steiner.
We can't do anything about that.
There's gotta be enough leg shots for you to work there.
Oh my god, this video's too long.
The main thing about this is I don't think any leg shot they
even got used, did they?
I think this, he's, if he wants a leg shot, maybe it's the
one where it was like him standing and we were like, That
has to be enough.
Maybe.
It was like us between his legs or whatever.
That sounds really terrible.
I don't think I know.
But yes, maybe.
Although I think, I don't think it was, but I think that
might have been like added afterwards.
So I think maybe this was all for nothing.
So that makes it even better.
Anyway.
That makes it even better, yeah.
What is this one?
I see.
The method acting.
Okay, Shirley, Shirley, that was...
Stop having to get off of this camera!
There's another Oscar for this performance.
It's brilliant.
Yeah, give him the Oscar right now for that full incredible
stuff.
okay surely surely well thank you so much that was stymus
torment section what do we think about that guys i feel
tormented he was tormenting i'm crying he didn't do this in
public no he did he did some of them in public but some of
the shots were did have to be filmed was in public some of
it was not incredible incredible stuff no but in all
seriousness I feel like Lord Loiter did have a very key part
in the MV so thank you for your hard work and all your green
screen bed sheet shots thank you so much thank you thank you
thanks for letting us kick you in the dirt bruh alright and
then Then we have...
We have some drafts of the MV.
The first drafts, guys!
The first drafts!
Oh no, these are so funny.
Very exciting.
Shall we watch the first one?
Are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Let's go.
We are Oh yes, that's a cello.
Show the world that we want to hit.
Sing out!
Show them nothing can stop it.
Break out!
Break the cycle of fate.
This is the...
Is this what we is in?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I think this is the original storyboard.
Oh, this one's being an intense story.
Yeah, the intense story.
Running like the sun as it sets upon the town in love.
Dance sets, we take our keep out.
The heart is set aflame by a call from up above.
cornel no worry i didn't turn out for a bit
yeah there's no lord loiter in there oh there he is there he
is wait low angle to make you be a little taller hello is
that what i want to say it's kind of the mystery for our
electric town will pave the way through all the hate light
up from magic until mandanake our passion heard in every
word with voices ringing out all over the world let's look
ahead kick bad guy yeah you'll see a brighter world
unfolding instead you'll see that one day the mpc will
become our new heroine all their story stuff all otaku Still
fun of you, boy!
Shout out!
Show the world that we wanted.
Sing out!
Show them nothing can stop it.
Break out!
Break the cycle of fate we're pushing through.
You can see why it got changed so much because we were a
little limited to the future.
We couldn't do so much dance job.
Yeah.
Cause we're stronger than ever.
Raise up!
Been like mightier than the sword.
I'm not sure we would have even been able to take the dawn.
The drone shots anyway.
Either way.
That's true.
I've had quite limited time at the aquarium.
It's getting real good now.
Let it rise, pierce the core Dance, dance, we do the punch
patch Once another round, oh this is me with my tornado
device today Oh yeah, there it is Now we're fading out in
front of the crowd Lighting the way I love the Phoebe demo
version Yeah I apologize, this is what was used for a while
Until we recorded it twice No, we like it, it's amazing We
are oh it's still playing okay give me a quick second
there's one i think the second one i haven't loaded in yet
so give me one sec i'm so sorry guys my brain is everywhere
with making sure that i loaded in everything give me two
seconds i'm just gonna quickly
please uh please talk in the meantime while i am locked in
it is it is so cool to see how things have changed because
even though even though you know it was intended to be one
way at the start it really became its most perfect form on
accident i think that's how a lot of our stuff goes vicky uh
what i was someone said make sure it has the version with
patched at the end of the file name yes Okay.
Both of them do.
I thought that would be important.
Yes.
Thank you.
I was like, oh no, what have I done?
Oh no.
No, no.
Awesome.
No, someone said that in the, in the, yeah.
I think because I haven't set up one of the videos
beforehand, it's just gonna, oh, oh no, I've got a new idea.
Okay.
This might be out of order.
Oh, I don't really want to do it out of order though.
Okay.
Um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um.
this should work because the source will be the same i'm so
sorry i'm just i'm trying to work things out so i can play
it okay okay all right are we ready for the next one let us
view Yeah!
Baby!
Babies!
We are dancing to the babies!
Baby!
This is so funny!
Babies!
Wait, wait, this is my favorite part right here.
Oh no, wait, I think it's the other version!
That your baby has was so oh my gosh yeah massive baby head
we're all big babies guys do you think we should have used
this in the final video let us know in the comments this is
the version i showed matara oh is it yeah it's so fun
with the strings from inside the spirit of the misled in me
thirst for our electric town we'll paint we can't get out of
the babies oh wait he's gonna fight his demons yeah oh no oh
there it is i don't even stop his arms just like go down the
original i wanted i wanted a kick instead so i was like can
i have the kick piece
okay they got us they got our voices mixed up there oh yeah
yeah there's a lot of like ninja's feet twisting at first
yeah wake up turn the right turn the right up because we're
stronger than ever
I wonder how we watch this and we're like, yeah, this will
be a coherent music.
This is part of the, this is the trust the process part, you
guys.
And big ups to Phoebe for singing this whole demo.
Thank you.
Thank you for the whole horse thing.
I think I was like super, I don't know, I think I had a lot
going on.
So I was like, oh guys, I can't record the demo for this
thing.
tomorrow yeah ah beautiful beautiful
is it like the old video no this is the new footage i was
wondering because those like sometimes when the footage
changed up as well this is the old footage yeah before i
told them to change I wanted it a little more cut, like
quick cuts too.
We'll pave the way through all the hate.
Light it up from Adi Kanto Mandarake.
Our passion heard in every word.
Make points of singing out all over the world.
Without the back routers.
I hope that this is true.
We'll be holding his neck.
You'll see that won't take me to be.
We'll become our new heroine.
So good.
For a while I thought it was gonna stay like this.
I thought it was gonna be just this skeleton here, yeah.
Yeah.
Show the world that we wanted.
Sing out.
Show nothing can stop it.
Break out.
Break the cycle of fate we're pushing through.
Wake up to the rise to the future.
Rise up.
Because we're stronger than ever.
Is grandma there still?
Oh no, grandma was a great addition.
No.
We blow off the salary man.
Whoa, so heiky cool you guys.
We have one more version to watch as well.
So give me a second.
Usual.
Second to last draft of MV patched.
MP4.
We have that one to watch as well.
You guys ready?
Yes.
Oh You're kind We are We are Show the world that we want
Showing nothing cancel Make it more go Break the cycle of
fate we're pushing through Wake up Turn the rise to the
future Yeah Big head Big head back Big head back
What can I say, guys?
Big brain.
Okay.
Why was it so big?
I still don't know.
It's so big.
Oh, it's got the red phone as well.
Oh.
I've been huddled down together with you by your side.
There's a baby tree and everything's like that.
What is this different?
Yeah, I've not seen a difference so far.
Yeah.
I pretty sure I didn't play the wrong one.
Let me know somewhere if I am playing the wrong one.
I don't think I am.
No, it's just another...
Oh, sorry, go ahead.
No, I think this is...
has something added to it.
I think you're correct.
Oh, well, see if some of the puppets are moving around
again.
Mmm.
The process.
And
we, and you think quit joking.
Raven's was fun.
We're not joking.
Yeah.
No, look at the one that he found.
Oh, that was coconut.
These drawings are so cute!
They're so good!
Beautiful!
Oh yeah!
I'm amazed, Minter, that you managed to puppeteer me and you
to head bang at different times.
How did you do that?
It was crazy.
It was fun.
I'm always known, I'm not alone.
But now I truly do believe in my soul.
This time was war.
I stand once more.
What once was broken has now become more.
I love you guys.
We were able to make sure something like this.
We'll never go down.
So stand your ground and sing your proud.
Our battle cries ringing out through the time.
Oh.
We'll pave the way through all the hate I'm from magic
I was gonna
be like this Like he took off his costume And it was just
normal Normal
I like the alternative I like the alternative Yeah, yeah,
yeah, I think it actually Yeah
What Oh, yeah, you see Yay
Oh my gosh, you guys, thank you so much We also have some
final comments I do believe as well Let me put that BGM back
on I think we have some comments from The lovely Julia Give
me a second do i i think i've can someone let me know if i
have missed anything but i believe this should be the last
thing is lovely comments from julia hey don't hi all
producer julia here thank you so much for allowing me to
work on burn on and to all you denshees for getting us to
100k big ups to julia yeah julia whoo whoo julia julia julia
julia julia Phoebe, can you read this one?
I will attempt.
It was an honor to work with these talented artists,
animators, illustrators...
Oh, wait, sorry.
It was an honor to work with these talented artists,
animators, illustrators, filmographers, editors, and, of
course, with...
Oh, with you.
The best group of all time.
I can't thank everyone enough.
And you're the best producer of all time.
Okay, real quick.
Julia?
Julia is, like, really the glue that helped this entire
thing come together.
Julia is, um, she's just, she's, she's a, she's a comfort
person of mine.
She's a comfort, you know, like a blurb.
Oh, she's a blurb.
Oh, we love her so very much.
So talented, like, so many talents that Julia has to be able
to bring these all together.
And so many, like, awesome people that she was able to bring
together.
for the MV just so cool.
Thank you.
I know.
She sourced like everybody.
It was awesome.
So cool.
Dozo Minto.
We've collected some comments and special behind the scenes
footage from these amazing creators that we hope you'll
enjoy.
Well, we enjoyed watching as much as we enjoyed breaking it.
I'm sorry if I did it out of order.
Sumimaset.
We've got a lot of fun things in the works.
So we here at Setsna, hope that you keep supporting Dead
Setsa.exe!
Burn on!
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay, yay!
They forgot the formal apology for putting me through
emotional distress.
Steiner, you enjoyed being part of the process.
I'm sure.
There was no order.
Oh, okay, awesome.
Wow.
Oh, I feel... I feel so...
I genuinely feel just so lucky right now to be able to, you
know, looking through everyone's hard work and seeing all
the behind the scenes and the many, many hours that these
incredible creators have spent on making this envy for us in
the way that we envision.
I just, I'm so hecking grateful.
How are you guys feeling?
No.
Me too.
Yeah.
It really was the dream team that came together.
And speaking of dream team, I also want to shout out one
more person.
I want to shout out Aina, who did such a wonderful job.
of like putting some of these graphic materials together for
us to use on stream who's always pulling through for us who
made the of course our thumbnail for the video as well and
who's also also an mvp too thank you so much for all your
hard work yeah yeah i think the music video is just so
everything densetsu everything like the team it's just the
whole process of it it was just like it really pushed
everybody's creativity to the limits and it was just so fun
and i it came out perfectly like there's nothing i would
change about it everything is moving
oh yeah thank you steiner thank you steiner as well yeah
honestly the whole team we would never actually explode you
we would not we love you too much i would that guy was
stressing me out damn well most most of the time most of the
time we would not explode you sometimes you do deserve it
it's okay someone's got to keep him in his place someone's
got to keep him in his place but no seriously just like yeah
what what's an honor to have such amazing creators uh create
this for us and being a part of our story i'm sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry me me i'm a part of the story me
um but no i yeah i'm just so grateful from the bottom of my
heart thank you all so much thank you for preparing
everything all the team for for getting everything together
Thank you so hegging much.
It's made it a really special 100k celebration to be able to
share all this stuff with you guys.
And I hope you guys enjoyed seeing these little tidbits from
behind the scenes.
Yeah.
Anything else we wanted to announce or whatever before we
MVP's out of it?
Well, one little teaser is that we will definitely,
definitely, be seeing all of these artists every single one
of them again in the future just as a teaser oh what does
that mean I don't know what could you mean what does that
mean actually oh really oh here I'll type it to you is it
still a secret
it's reminded me of the time where it's like the
announcement and me what's happening all right oh I see I
see oh that's fun okay guys look forward to that little
secret thing secret thing that Phoebe's hinting at yeah oh
it's been so much fun to hang out with you guys and and you
know look at the behind the scenes of this special special
special thing that we made together so thank you guys hope I
did it all job of loading everything it seems like i have
yeah thank you thank you oh my gosh thank you i was like
panicking the whole time i'm literally sweating i can see
the sweat like rolling down my arm for me no you were fine
you did great you did fantastic amazing thanks guys i'm
sorry i'm sorry that i that my model faced in and out of
existence like 30 times during this no and i You're telling
me, actually, it's stable now.
That's funny.
It's got a chance, but, you know, I like Robo, Phoebe.
Stop, the model stopped freezing out of the... No, wait.
Oh, okay.
It, like, stopped for a moment, but it's because I covered
my face.
I was like, no, there's no way it's happening now.
Yeah.
Keen to see you guys at Smash in a few weeks.
Yeah, we got that coming up.
Who's going to see us?
Australia.
I'm not going to drop that.
and the marmite.
Yeah.
The marmite.
Sorry, Vegemite.
Vegemite.
The Vegemite behind your ear.
Behind your ear?
Yeah, behind your ear.
That's how you get rid of the drop bears.
That's how you scare them away.
You've got to get the Vegemite.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be careful, guys.
Good to know.
Are they afraid of it?
Do they smell it?
Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe, I mean, Vegemite's like marmite, right?
Like, either love it or you hate it.
I guess drop bears hate it.
Yeah.
They hate it.
I guess so.
have eucalyptus and blood.
Wait, our koalas like, eucalyptus is like poisonous.
Or like something, they eat stuff that's poisonous for them,
Or something silly.
It gives them some kind of disease.
I don't remember what it was.
It is, yeah.
It is like poisonous.
And I think from what I remember it makes their butt leak.
But then the babies lick that.
And...
Is that good for the babies?
I guess.
Wow, koalas, such sweet animals.
That sounds so sweet.
I don't know how they still is.
They're like pandas.
How are they not extinct?
Come on.
Any other little announcements from you guys?
Any exciting streams coming up?
You want to chat about before we MVP sell?
I don't know.
I'm gonna be accepting, well, I am currently accepting more
Q&A questions for our monthly advice stream that i've
neglected to do for the past two months but if you guys have
anything you want advice on go submit questions i'll post
the link up again soon oh vicky really trying to make mvps
out happen guys serenade can i just talk about skyline
serenade real quick skyline serenade yeah talk about it guys
yeah yeah yeah yeah so oh in fact if i were to send Yes.
On the screen.
Okay, where the heck is my Skyline Serenade graphic?
Okay, let me...
I will go download it and send it to you real quick.
But yes, are you going to be in New York City for an anime,
a NYC, or do you just happen to be in New York City around,
like, the middle slash end of August?
I'll be there.
What's happening, baby?
Wait, there is a show that two of us will be in called
Skyline Serenade.
Here is the graphic for it.
Very pretty graphic.
Give me a second.
Yes, thank you, Vicky.
And who's going to be part of it, I wonder?
Hmm, can you guys guess?
But also, if you're not going to be in New York, there will
be streaming tickets to Roe.
Yes.
Roe.
also there are streaming tickets up for legends and news
still so please go buy that yeah go go go go go go see
lovely lovely mint and febi on the stage and maybe some
other friends will be there too maybe some other friends
yeah but yeah those of you guys that are like oh wow that
that was actually them in the music video that that's the
outfit from the music my outfit from the music video right
there.
It is!
It really is!
And that's my outfit from the music video.
Yeah, that's your outfit from the music video.
But yeah, thank you all again.
Skyline Serenade.
Lots of love too.
Live from the Beacon Theater.
And not Bacon, the Beacon Theater.
Oh, Bacon Theater!
Also, sounds great.
I just think of Burger Bacon, Burger Bacon.
hey guys i think i did a pretty good job when you guys you
did you did it was great yeah i could have ever imagined and
i whipped that accent out at off car you know yeah beautiful
yeah amazing oh i have an announcement oh yeah an
announcement oh yeah maybe oh oh keep an eye out oh yeah So
basically check mint socials every day for the next like two
weeks just to be just to be safe.
Oh, we have the last explosion.
The last just Phoebe ran out of frame so we didn't use it in
the video.
I fired a flight trigger and I ran too fast.
I had a feeling I had a feeling I was running too fast.
My bad.
Do we want to show that as the last thing?
sure you guys want to see the lost explosion oh wait you
want me to check it real quick do you want me to check it
I'll check it only six seconds oh I'll check it I'll be
right back and check it hang on but it's totally up to you
totally up to you uh Choto minute I'm gonna have a little
look at it oh do you guys want to keep chatting i'll go
check it um um have you eaten dinner yet mental yeah i had a
chicken biscuit on stream oh that sounds so good was it a
delicious one chat do you guys remember if it was delicious
was the response positive it was delicious not maybe not
nutritious very buttery oh oh butter bacon bun bacon burger
burger burger Burger, burger, burger, burger, burger.
Burger, burger, burger, bacon, butter, burger.
I'm gonna have curry after this.
I had curry the other night, too.
Ooh.
Does Vicky have dinner planned out yet, even though it's
quite early for dinner?
I have a late lunch planned out, but I will tell you guys
about that late.
I will show photos.
Let's.
Let's send a photo.
Secret lunch.
That might be everything though.
Oh, I think we're going to show the final explosion as the
final.
Are we happy?
Are we all happy before I do it though?
If you guys are happy, I'm happy.
Yeah, it's...
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
Okay, okay.
Alrighty, Joto minute then.
Gonna give me a little second, you guys.
The Lost Explosion.
I think it's a little anticlimactic.
That's a lot.
Everything we've seen already.
I know, I feel like...
That's why I was like, who do we show it?
It's a little anticlimactic, but...
You know.
Behind the scenes is fun.
give me a second uh for a reason all right chuto a minute
i'm hoping that this will work fine okay music off final
explosion here we go i think that's it we go hopefully it
looks like it could be yeah
Yeah!
Slow-mo running.
See?
Oh, it's me after that.
You can see how like urgent...
I feel like it's a lot more obvious how urgently we're
running from this side of the shore, isn't it?
Amazing.
Well, there you go, guys.
One little final treat for you guys.
Did you enjoy it?
Oh, did you guys even hear that?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
You can hear the video.
Oh, they heard.
Okay, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Good, good, good.
Thank you, MVP.
Thank you, guys.
And thank you so much to all of the amazing, amazing,
amazing staff and everyone who was in the MV who came
together to put everything together for today.
I know it must have taken a lot of work.
So thank you so, so heckin' much.
Thank you.
Yes, thank you.
Oh, Jolo, thank you for the other super as well.
Oh, thank you.
so much for the Aga Spa.
It's been so much fun watching burn on over and over.
There's clearly so much love and ever put into the project
from start to finish and it truly shows it's a masterpiece.
Kudos to everyone involved.
Thank you so much you guys.
And with that, I'm gonna make it a thing guys.
You're saying, you know, Vicky, you can't make it a thing.
I will make it a thing.
MV peace out.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you so much, you guys.
Anything else to add or shall we MV peace out?
I want to envy peace out all right guys thank you so much
envy peace out thank you everyone thank you